لا مسار جديه للتسويه حتى الان يكبح مسار
الحرب في اوكرانيا غير ان المنابر
السياسيه في العواصم المنخرطه في ذلك
النزاع بشكل او باخر لا تخلو من حديث شبه
يوميا عن السلام في موسكو اعلن المتحدث
باسم الكربلا ان روسيا تتفق مع الولايات
المتحده بشان الحاجه الى اقرار سلام دائم
في اوكرانيا لكنها لا ترى في الوقت الراهن
فرصه لاجراء مفاوضات معكيف واكد المتحدث
ضروره تحقيق بلاده اهداف عمليتها العسكريه
الخاصه قبل اجراء اي محادثات
اوكرانيا ايضا تبدو معنيه بالسلام لكن فقط
كما تراه هي ان يغادر الجيش الروسي
اراضيها طواعيه او بالقوه
والاصعب والاقصى ونعرف ان الثمن غال ولكن
هدفنا هو تحرير ارضنا وحمايه بلدنا اعتقد
اننا سنلتقي في المرات المقبله في دنياك
الاوكرانيه
وشبه جزيره الكرم المحرره خطاب تعبوي
للداخل تزامنا مع رسائله تحملها المسيارات
مفادها ان اوكرانيا باتت قادره على ايلام
روسيا داخل اراضيها بعد استهداف مطارات
روسيه
تبدو هذه معادله جديده وهي مثل ما تؤجج
الحرب يمكنها لاحقا التاثير ايجابا على
مجريات الاحداث وتفكير صناع القرار
العسكريين والسياسيين احاديث التسويه
وسلام تردد صداها ايضا في تيران عاصمه
البانيا حيث يعقد قاده دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي قمه مع نظرائهم في دول غرب
البلقان السته قبل ذلك اكد مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي ان حل
النزاع يتطلب تقديم ضمانات امنيه
لاوكرانيا اولا
ولروسيا لاحقا
وفي الولايات المتحده توقع وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انتهاء الصراع في اوكرانيا
بالطرق الدبلوماسيه داعيا كياف الى تحديد
النطاق المستقبلي للحرب وشروط انهائها